emmanuel macron n'est pas un président
qui réforme c'est un président qui
fracture qui divise la société française
et dont les paroles parfois justes ne
sont jamais suivies d'effet et donc les
français ne croient plus en la parole
présidentielle
d'ailleurs dans le cadre plus largement
de la réforme des retraites je demande
nous demandant les christian jacob un
geste d'apaisement c'est à dire qu
emmanuel macron retire alors ça c'est
celle non réforme des retraites avec
emmanuel macron vous aurez davantage de
régime régimes spéciaux à la fin de son
mandat qu'avance au monde emmanuel
macron ment aux français ils avaient dit
qu'il y aurait pas de report de l'âge
légal
il augmente et multiplie le nombre de
régimes spéciaux ils rackettent les
professions libérales les artisans et
les commerçants nous nous proposons une
réforme juste c'est à dire financer une
réforme qui supprime maintenant tous les
régimes spéciaux tous
il ne peut pas nier tous les régimes
spéciaux et comment vous vion produisons
des métiers pénibles
alors attendez nous proposons aussi la
garantie d'autonomie des caisses des
professions libérales qui sont bien
gérées néant voilà par exemple et enfin
nous proposons une prise en compte
inédite de la pénibilité parce que vous
avez raison c'est un sujet majeur par
exemple nous mettrons bientôt sur la
table avec les républicains une
proposition très novatrice sur la
pénibilité c'est à dire que pour tous
les métiers pénibles reconnues par la
médecine du travail
tous les cinq ans une année de
bonification parce que les métiers
pénibles les carrières hachées les
carrières dur les carrières longues
doivent être récompensés
la seule réforme des retraites possible
sur le temps long c'est une réforme
fondée sur la justice sociale
l' inverse du président la république